um and looks like the knight is one but  rookie seven looks like an excellent  move  because if that pawn drops then  basically f6 has ruined black's pawn  structure of course anish understands  this  um it's gone  knight f ford's  knight maybe this could just be a draw  now  could just be a draw  let me just recap those moves f6  rookie seven rook here threatening the  check on f1  knight at four rook back there yeah  repeating  i think it's just going to be a draw and  that means anish will be out  yeah there we go  because it's too late dany you can't  defend the e6 pawn and that is it  wow that's a draw with that i think i'm  sure anisha's checking what happens but  we do have confirmation that  with this draw  lenia is in and anish is out of the  quarterfinals